Hey David.
When do primary poles start to mean something?
Um, this came in from a lot of people, including
from Austin, Wenger via Twitter.
In other words, when can we look at pot primary
polling data and historically say, now this
is probably giving us a good sense of when
of who the nominees are ultimately going to
be.
Let's just look at the data.
Okay.
We're currently 12 or 13 months out from the
conventions, which are in July and August
of next year.
We're about 17 months out from the 2020 election.
So this is like equivalent to early July,
2015 for the 2016 election.
If you go back to July 5th, 2015 Donald Trump
was only polling six and a half percent.
So the idea there is you really aren't going
to know in July of the year before who's going
to win.
The primary.
Trump was polling only six and a half percent
in July, early July of 2015 he eventually
won the nomination.
However, by July 18th of 2015, Donald Trump
was tied for first place in the Republican
primary.
Um, and from then on he was basically ahead
to the end with the exception of a couple
of polls in November of 2015.
So on the republican side, historically by
late July, like two weeks from now, uh, you
would know or you would expect that the leader
in the primary polls would be the nominee.
Now on the democratic side, if we look at
July five, 2015, which again is equivalent
to today, Hillary Clinton was polling 63 and
Bernie Sanders was polling 14.
Now, What's interesting about the 2015 democratic
primary is that Hillary did lose that advantage
to Bernie all the way up to April of 2016
where Bernie got within five points of Hillary
Clinton.
But then again, Hillary Clinton built that
lead back up.
And as we know, she ultimately was the eventual
winner of the 2016 primary.
So in 2016 primary, the eventual winner on
the democratic side, Hillary Clinton was leading
all along.
But I know you will say, and I agree, 2016
in the DNC primary, there were certainly some
irregularities there.
So what if instead we look at 2008, the reason
we won't look at 2012 is Obama was just the
incumbent and there was no a primary challenge
to him.
Not a serious one that I can remember anyways.
So if we look at 2008 in July of 2007, which
is equivalent to right now, uh, Hillary Clinton
was ahead of Barack Obama.
July 5th, 2007.
It was Hillary 37, Obama 23 and of course,
eventually Barack Obama did win that primary.
So that is the glimmer of hope that those
who don't want to see Joe Biden be the nominee.
Like me, I don't, Joe Biden is not someone
that I'm supporting, uh, are looking at.
Now, as we know, uh, Barack Obama didn't take
the lead until February of 2008, which is
still several months from today, equivalently.
So the takeaway is listen, in general, in
July of the year before the primary, certainly
by the end of July, almost always the person
who's leading the polls ends up being the
nominee.
In cases where the July leader loses the lead
and does not get the nomination, um, the person
who does is not that far behind, they're polling
second.
Maybe there's some examples of where they're
pulling third.
So what this would tell us about 2020 is that
if it's not going to be Joe Biden who's the
nominee, and again, statistically the most
likely thing is historically Biden is the
nominee.
If it's not going to be Biden history tells
us it will be someone who is already polling
well, which in my mind means if it's not Biden,
it's going to be Bernie or Elizabeth Warren
or Kamala Harris.
Now there are those who say everything is
different in 2020.
We can't go at all by what has happened historically
with these primaries.
And if that's the case, then throw everything
I set out the window and anybody could win
what I think everybody should be doing.
Given the fact that it's likely we know where
this is going to go in terms of who is in
this thing, but that may not be the case.
Vote for whoever aligns with your values on
policy, activate and campaign for those people.
That's all we can do and demand that the DNC
run this thing fairly, but that is where history
tells us.
Polling starts to matter and it's basically
right around.
Now, if you disagree with me, let
me know.
We've got a great bonus show in plenty more
time to discuss this there